[Music]
os login is a compute engine offering
that provides a way to manage ssh access
to linux virtual machine instances using
iem roles
when os login is enabled a linux user
account is directly tied to a user's
google identity
this means that a user has a specific
username and uid in all os login vms in
their project organization
with os login you can also restrict root
access
you can enable os login for individual
vms or for all vms in your project to
enable os login for a specific vm go to
the compute engine vm instances page and
select your instance
start editing the instance and navigate
to the custom metadata section
you want to add the key enabled os login
and set the value to true then click
save
os login is now enabled on this instance
and only users with the appropriate iem
roles can connect to the vm using ssh
alternatively you can enable os login
for all the instances in your project by
navigating to the compute engine
metadata page and adding enable dash os
login with the value
true once this metadata key is added os
login is enabled on all linux vms in the
project you can disable those login on a
specific instance by adding the metadata
enable os login to false at the instance
level
you can also enable os login when
creating a vm in the advanced security
options we will go over how to do this
in a later example to grant a user
permission to connect to vms that have
os log enabled the user must have the
required os login iam rules
let's take a closer look at these roles
compute os admin login
allows the user to ssh into the instance
and run commands as an administrator
while computeros login allows them to
ssh in without administrative access
the iim service account user role allows
a user to run operations as a service
account this is a necessary permission
to log into a vm that is associated with
the service account you can grant the
compute os login roles at the instance
level or at the project level so they
apply to all resources inside your
project
the service account user role can be
granted on the project or on individual
service accounts in scenarios where
users outside your organization require
access to your vms your organization
administrator must grant the compute os
log an external user role to those users
at the organization level
let's run through an example
we will start by creating a compute
engine instance we are going to leave
all the fields as default scroll down
and expand to the security section here
you can see the manage access section
and the option control vm access to iem
permissions
this will ensure that our newly created
vm will have os login enabled
let's attempt to ssh into the vm as a
user without the compute admin role
and is unsuccessful
this is expected because we have not yet
given the necessary permissions to this
user account
let's go ahead and grant the appropriate
iem roles to my user account
in the scenario we would like this user
to be able to ssh into the vm but not
run any commands as the root account
therefore we need to grant this user the
compute os login role
now let's try to ssh once again
wait a few seconds
and we are able to ssh into the vm
successfully
in summary os login can simplify ssh
access management your compute engine
instances by using iam roles when
granting these roles always keep in mind
the security best practice of lease
privilege and set your permissions
accordingly
[Music]